what is Hugh Grant's favorite film Hugh
Grant Eva yes Sound of Music it's a
difficult situation I'm married to a
Swedish woman who comes from the North
of Sweden where men are really men
they're so manly they hardly speak and
they chop wood what they don't do is
watch The Sound of Music in the
afternoons and sing along with the
Mother Superior when she sings Climb
Every Mountain and they certainly don't
cry when the father because of a plumber
is touched by his children singing and
then joins in but I do cry
but it's impeccable the film is
impeccable it's not a single moment I
don't love and I sometimes go to those
uh you know you can have a whole party
where you you screen the film and
everyone dresses up as characters I
think it was Elton John's 60th was like
that I went as the baroness
wow